uh i need to like put this table higher
because i need to
[Music]
sorry
i mean the camera's not on you so it
doesn't matter
[Music]
all these dudes
they want a wifey
they wanna be my for life
[Music]
i'm going downtown to the bar
[ __ ] you already know that i'm a star
but don't you dare take it too far
i'ma kick you out this [ __ ] car
a losing bar
no i'm sub bar i said bar
see how already they feel
yeah no
i love it
i need to get me one of those yeah
they're expensive though this one's like
70 bucks
and i have to like so i have really big
thighs right so i have to cut this 70
yeah
but like i had to
well like i feel like shapewear is worth
it if you get a good one like a good one
you learn when you're thinking when i
was skinny i never understood mm-hmm but
like this see how tight it is on my
thighs yeah so it went down to here and
it was just like it was too much so i
have to i had to cut it short i might
cut it shorter actually into like
this it rolls up here anyway
put a word in the chat no i don't drink
guys
put a word in the chat i'll try to
freestyle to it
this is kind of fun
i'm not very good but
i could
well i used to do it with my
ex-boyfriend all the time
[Music]
see like i don't look like this
oh that is pretty short
yeah
but i can wear my
see the back is just like really
i like the front a lot it's just like
that slit makes it so short
i don't know how to say that obsequious
[Music]
the 18th is great for craft beer i told
those boys to get out of here yeah i'm
that [ __ ]
that they fear so when they see me
they gotta steer left like this oh i
like that actually yeah
it's a little [ __ ] but like i feel
like i can make it work
yeah i think you can i'm gonna stretch
it out
you all don't even know the struggle of
being tall this one's doing an extra job
[Music]
and these dudes they want foreplay oh
and they go the wrong way stay
bright tight light white fight okay i'm
trying to stay out all night yeah
every day i do what's right okay
and i wear this dress that's kind of
tight
super
flowers
okay okay okay i don't know
i don't know what super flowers means
but i know that i need you on my team
and i'm gonna get seven rings okay
there go
bling bling
bling and twerk your ass that thing
every day
i'm gonna sing yeah
every day i'll do my thing okay
because every day all i alla all i do is
win
ah
okay that's not how you pronounce it i
don't know i'm sorry i can't read
sorry i don't i'm not that smart
yeah like
give me easier words then there's a
reason we came to the uk for our masters
yeah
that's all i have to do
like
yeah we're not we're not we're
[Music]
go right through us
talk
i need to get me one of those or i could
just lose weight
i don't know because i like being thick
like this kind of took a second i wanna
lose 20 pounds i'm so tired of all this
digging around
and when i drop the weights they don't
make a sound
but
you know what i found the [ __ ] ice
cream i love it too much
that thick vanilla got that touch but i
got a special place in my heart for
chocolate
that's the reason why i don't get fit
oh my god
okay super flawless
is that that's the word you want me to
use how old am i i'm 25.
super
wait wait super flowest
super what does that mean
super
they call me superb man
they say i'm better than peter pan
super flawless don't know what that is
and i feel like i'm do win quiz
tis
i don't know
i'm lost
if you were a frenchman and you saw me
would you be like
okay guys if you were a frenchman would
you approach gabby no don't we ask that
question because that's a loaded
question because they'll be like no
she's fat and ugly and i'll be like
all right okay i i don't think my
followers are usually pretty nice
like
hold on the internet are pretty ruthless
that's true they do like you could like
i've seen girls that are like skinny and
stunning and people roast the [ __ ] out
of them and i'm like
i'm not skinny i'm
pretty but i'm not skinny so i'm like
you all want to roast me on some [ __ ] i
know some people wait and i'm insecure
about this
oh my god
they said absolutely she's got
front long legs i'm not french but i
would i would approach unless she looked
angry i always look angry
okay well i guess you would not be
getting approached
how old is your friend 25 wait now 22
i'm 25.
[Music]
guys i'm gonna be a rapper one day i'm
gonna release a track
i would okay so okay funny story not
really funny but like
okay so when i had cobia
and i was i told you the story earlier
like i was so sick like i didn't eat
anything for two weeks
like
i was throwing up all the time because i
kept gagging i was so sick and i was
taking a lot of nyquil right and it made
me like delusional and so i would like
be asleep but i'd have these like fish
it wasn't my dreams it was vision okay
and i would be on stage freestyling in
my vision and it was like [ __ ] bars
bars
and it was so clear in my head and i was
just like
no anxiety i was just [ __ ] going off
and i was like [ __ ] and that but now
like i'm like i can't do that but like
in my head in my vision i was like
all i want to do is be a mediocre rapper
i don't want to be good i want to be
mediocre you know what i mean average
[Music]
[Music]
here's a shot to
the viewers
okay i don't drink but she's gonna take
a shot cheers cheers
[Music]
lost my phone
can i wear my black boots
these ones all right hold up
um
yeah i like those boots
i'll wear my black purse
oh wait
[Music]
am i scheduled with tori now not for
tonight for monday nights we're gonna do
[Music]
every day um
i don't know if i can adapt to this one
i need an easier one
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you make me wish i was taller
[Music]
yeah if i was a guy i'd probably want to
be really
tall just makes your life easier i think
dating wise you get so many it just
perks in life
thank you
work through
how did the frito bang collab come about
i just asked i dm rappers all the time
asking if they'll collab with me because
i think those videos are funny
and he was just the only one that
responded
hey hey
something for me if i call you if i just
say that again you're forgettable that's
why i didn't want to do you guys podcast
that's forgettable hate the setup uh the
name is underwhelming i didn't
really see the value in it i got you
looking at the thumbnail
you're looking at the title of the video
y'all already know what time it is it is
time
to get active
okay guys i feel like i should end this
live
are you on my live
no i was taking a video from my mother
maybe i shouldn't are there 17 people on
here maybe i'll keep it
maybe i'll keep it
there's gonna be a good conversation
that we're about to have here today guys
let me describe why this conversation is
as pivotal is as
interesting as what it's going to be oh
my god should we go
you have to it's almost midnight
it's almost one in the morning i did not
realize how late it is oh my god it's 12
30 i know that's what i'm saying it's so
11 30
oh my gosh
i don't know who king richie's is but
that's important because there's been a
lot too much everything on to uh in the
mail space and it leaves a lot of people
scratching their french men approach us
like a lot
like faster than americans i would say
recently
their talking points versus who they
family don't stand for which is the
ideologies of people
right the reality and the thinking of an
independent woman
stands for i mean yeah but speaks
just depends if you care
[Music]
do you have a difference
which is inherently very interesting so
we're going to discuss it here today
guys also notice that i'm not going to
play the visual to avoid anything right
issues i'll leave a link to the full
podcast down in the
oh my god bars and clubs close at 2 a.m
here
it's one
wait
oh
um i would say frenchmen are a lot more
direct oh my god they're so red all this
[ __ ] closes even sooner 1 30. a long
period of time
feedback where guys can become resentful
and there's a lot of information that's
shared but the numbers get done on the
right
and they can't keep
[Music]
because you know that those turn up the
numbers but the key question asking is
not necessarily refreshing because
they're gonna absorb the increase of the
dollars of the extra entertainment that
crowd comes but for the man that's
watching what does that say about your
mental state you can arrive [ __ ] out
yeah
i think
her point of view
well i'm not exactly typical person let
me think about it like this oh i like
that that's so cute i like that a lot
a croissant someone sent me five dollars
thank you sir
i'm so broke you don't even understand
i've been working so hard
more direct is it good or bad it's good
if we like you it's bad if we don't like
you should i
i haven't been hitting them by anyone i
like if i put on my black bra then i can
take my jacket off but this is cute
because i look curvy i like it i think
that's really cute it makes me want
shapewear
oh girl this is sucking it in this don't
oh my gosh i need there's usually rolls
here so
or maybe here
okay
now i'll just get by another the thing i
like about traveling is i think i would
be sad if i was by myself but like if
i'm out like it's really hard to be sad
you know well i'm like more fun
um
the only thing is i need to change my
bra
okay but i can
i'll
well i didn't know everything closed so
early here
guys we're irresponsible
i just felt god's all over myself and
that just added to it
oh
for real i um sad i get sad because um
never mind
um
i digress
this back here and then it would be fine
see i wish i had a little shapewear just
oh i'm not this skinny
like hold on
move a little
this is not real this is shapewear i'm
usually a lot go change your bra okay
let's go
um
okay
i for real
okay
okay i guess we'll go to the bars right
now
oh my gosh
okay i got
this jacket
ah
okay i know i should take off the fitbit
but i really like the fitbit
can't beat a red dress my friend is
yummy okay that's
she i mean
i don't know okay
hmm
hey
oh i have to take this down
freaking hey
okay
okay guys
we're gonna
okay you look sexy thank you thank you i
just can't believe this all
ends
yeah
like
i'm not even
ugh
[ __ ]
okay guys
we're going to try to go
i'm gonna facetime you guys in an hour
because
yeah all right
bye